l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur le
thème les enjeux nationaux et
internationaux de la future pac à la
demande du groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain la parole est tout d'abord
aux orateurs du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat et la parole est à monsieur jean
claude tissot pour le groupe socialiste
et écologiste républicains pour 4
minutes m
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mes chers collègues le groupe
socialistes écologistes et républicains
souhaitaient à l'inscription de ce débat
sur cette question fondamentale des
enjeux de la prochaine pac
parmi les politiques européennes
l'impact tient une place à part elle
reste en effet à ce jour la seule
véritable politique européenne intégrée
dotée d'un budget spécifique
quant à notre pays il en est aujourd'hui
le premier bénéficiaire après des
premières annonces inquiétantes l'accord
du conseil européen du 21 juillet 2020 a
finalement permis un relatif maintien du
budget de la pac en euros courants à
hauteur de 386 milliards la france
bénéficiera ainsi d'une enveloppe stable
à hauteur de 62 4 milliards d'euros 51
milliards sur le premier pilier et 11,4
milliards sur le second pourtant le
maintien faciale de ce budget qui est en
réalité une baisse car exprimé en euros
courants
il ne prend pas en compte l'inflation
avec une inflation à 2% par an sur la
période
on perd en réalité 39 milliards en euros
constants par rapport au budget
précédent pour plus qu'une année d'agde
aides du premier pilier
cette baisse qui n'est qu'en partie
imputable aux briques site n'est pas un
bon signal
alors que les défis qui sont devant nous
n'ont jamais été aussi grand parmi ces
défis inscrit parmi les dix objectifs
cette nouvelle pac
je retiendrai notamment assurer un
revenu équitable agriculteurs agir
contre le changement climatique
garantir la qualité des denrées
alimentaires et la santé ou encore
dynamiser le soutien est encore
dynamiser et soutenir le développement
économique des zones rurales comme vous
le voyez face à de tels enjeux ce n'est
pas le moment de baisser la garde
le plan stratégique national ou psn est
la grande nouveauté c'est tuture pas
qu'à partir de 2023
chaque état membre devoir
obligatoirement mettre en place un psn
qui définira les modalités de mise en
oeuvre opérationnelle de la pac à leur
échelle nationale
nous devons être très vigilants ce que
cette subsidiarité accrue ne fasse pas
perdre le sens du ces de pâques qui doit
être résolument préserver en effet si
les déclinaisons dts elle revenait à
faire autant de politiques agricoles
qu'il ya d'états membres des distorsions
voire du camping pourraient apparaître
il faut je répète que la pac reste une
politique collective et que tous les
agriculteurs quel que soit leur pays
sauf traités sur un même pied d'égalité
en outre le psn dont permettre que les
agriculteurs l'agriculture bio ne sont
pas la grande oubliée de la future pac
actuellement seulement 2% de la pac sont
consacrés à la bio ce qui est loin
d'être suffisant car pour atteindre
l'objectif de 25 % terres cultivées en
bio en 2030 fixés dans la stratégie
biodiversité farm tout forte il faut des
mesures fortement incitative pour
transformer les pratiques agricoles le
psn qui conditionnera les règles
d'attribution des aides pourrait donc
être le levier pour se rapprocher de
l'objectif de 15% surfaces bio en france
à l'horizon 2020 2 que vous aviez
réaffirmé monsieur mini d'un cadre du
plan ambition bio il en aura besoin
qu'en 2020 nous étions seulement à huit
et demi pour cent c'est dans ce sens que
nous avons signé une tribune avec 300
élus locaux et nationaux de différentes
sensibilités à l'initiative de la
fédération nationale de culture bio
appelant le gouvernement à intégrer
l'objectif du bio dans psn l'autre enjeu
de cette nouvelle pac c'est une
meilleure redistribution des subventions
le 21 juin 2020 le conseil a validé le
principe de plafonnement des aides à
hauteur de cent mille euros par
exploitation
les états membres auront en outre la
faculté de mettre en place un mécanisme
progressif de réduction des aides à
partir de soixante mille euros ce
plafonnement à 100000 euros nous sommes
déjà trop peu ambitieux d'autant plus ce
qui n'est finalement que facultatif
aussi j'espère que notre père et notre
pays se saisira de ces mécanismes de
plafonnement et de des christie de
dégressivité car sans un réel
plafonnement monsieur le ministre
sarr et un plafonnement des aides tout
le reste n'est que de la littérature
je terminerai par un mot sur les enjeux
internationaux cette nouvelle pac les
objectifs de cette future pac vont dans
le bon sens mais ils sont en complète
contradiction avec ce que l'europe en
même temps fait avec le c'est à dire que
ce soit les normes sanitaires et
environnementales que la france et lui
impose à nos agriculteurs ont fait
évoluer leurs pratiques faisant de notre
agriculture l'une des plus sûres au
monde d'autant plus vertueuses en
matière de protection de l'environnement
or ces évolutions ont un coût pour nos
agriculteurs en termes d'investissements
de formation et de prise de risque a
contrario avec le cetime bercot sourds
luode permettre d'ouvrir marché européen
à des produits alimentaires moins cher
mais s'affranchissant des noms
sanitaires et environnementales qui
s'imposent à nos paysans
c'est pourquoi je voudrais terminer mon
intervention par une question très
solennelle monsieur le ministre
quand aurons nous enfin un vrai débat
avec vous sur ses traités et leurs
conséquences sur l'agriculture et
l'alimentation dans notre pays je vous
remercie et recoller
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
monsieur christian renonce à raser pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicains pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis une
trentaine d'années chaque phase de
négociations de la pac constitue une
période d'incertitude pour les
professionnels du monde agricole en
particulier pour les éleveurs
c'est précisément la définition des
arbitrages pour réputé répartir en
budget en baisse qui ouvre le champ de
vives inquiétudes de la part de nombreux
territoires et du fil hier le 7 avril
dernier
vous avez notamment rappelé au sénat
monsieur le ministre que la pac
française devait encourager
l'agriculture des territoires avec une
atteste une attention portée aux
spécificités locales
le maintien d ici à chaîne et une
meilleure prise en compte des autres
intermédiaires mais faute d'une
définition officielle est unique
l'identification de ces zones
intermédiaires et donc le ciblage de
leur raid est bien plus difficile que
pour les zones défavorisées qui
bénéficient par exemple de li chn
le critère géographique est lui-même
variable selon les appréciations puisque
les pouvoirs publics
si tu les zones intermédiaires sur une
diagonale allant de la charente au grand
test
mais cette interprétation arbitraire
exclu de nombreux territoires par
exemple en région nouvelle aquitaine
l'occitanie qui pourtant semblerait
parmi les plus concernés un travail de
définition précise des zones
intermédiaires est donc attendue de
votre part monsieur le ministre il nous
faudra aussi savoir comment celles-ci
seront identifiés au sein de la nouvelle
pac et de quelles aides spécifiques
elles pourront bénéficier à l'image 10
chf
pour ces dernières le maintien au niveau
actuel com vous proposait de le faire
pose question pour atteindre cet
objectif il faudra que la france le
finançant son budget pour combler la
baisse du taux de cofinancement européen
de 10% actée par le conseil en octobre
dernier
c'est un arbitrage qui se défend mais
qui aura nécessairement enveloppe
globale constante des conséquences sur
les autres
z à cet égard les zones de polyculture
élevage et les professionnels d'élevage
allaitant craignent que le rééquilibrage
de l'envelope des aides couplées en
faveur de notre autonomie pratique ne se
fassent à leur dépens ces aides couplées
représentent actuellement 13% maximum de
l'envelope des aides directes
et 2% pour les protéines végétales or le
gouvernement envisage une augmentation
jusqu'à 4 % des aides dédiées aux
protéines afin de renforcer notre
indépendance alimentaire et de limiter
le recours aux importations
laurélie fait louable mais les
exploitations précité qui ont déjà pour
certaines étaient sortis du dispositif
de li chn et qui demeure fragile ne
pourront pas supporter une nouvelle
diminution par exploitation
le montant des aides allouées correspond
à peu près aux salaires mensuels des
éleveurs c'est-à-dire 800 euros par mois
si le rééquilibrage doit y avoir il
devra engager financièrement les
filières agricoles les moins impactées
par la crise par ailleurs notre groupe
attend des avancées sur le sujet des
paiements redistributif et sur la
convergence des aides si rien n'est
encore acté
je tiens tout de me rappeler que c'est
être couplé bénéficie pour 80% l'élevage
la fédération bovine
sam est fait l'écho en demandant à ce
que les aides couplées du premier pilier
soit impérativement maintenues à leur
niveau actuel
il en va de la survie de nombreuses
exploitations et donc plus largement de
l' équilibre économique mais aussi
environnemental de nombreux territoires
ruraux
l'élevage extensif qui les caractérise
grâce aux prairies permanentes
contribuer à la captation du carbone et
permet l'approvisionnement des
agglomérations proches de ces
exploitations en produits de qualité via
des circuits courts
il présente donc de nombreux avantages
qui correspond aux objectifs fixés par
la loi et galim en matière
d'accessibilité unanime à une
alimentation saine et durable
le volet équilibre des relations
commerciales entre producteurs et grande
distribution de la loi et en échec
manifeste après trois ans de mise en
oeuvre
on serait donc en droit d'attendre du
gouvernement un soutien massif en faveur
de ce modèle agricole
d'autre part une question demeure
concernant l'augmentation de notre
autonomie protéique d'israël en priorité
l'alimentation animale ou humaine
sur ce point les éleveurs manquent de
précision surtout face aux choix du
gouvernement de pérenniser le repas
végétariens hebdomadaire dans les
cantines scolaires
face à ces multiples impératif préserver
notre modèle d'élevage extensif et
augmenter notre autonomie protéique où
placer le curseur
comment arbitrer monsieur le ministre je
crois qu'il faut savoir avant tout de
quel modèle agricole nous voulons est ce
modèle qui promet des pratiques tant
d'élevage que de culture vertueuse et
respectueux de l'environnement des
animaux et des hommes
ou bien un modèle agriculture intensive
dont on ne cesse de rappeler les
multiples effets dévastateurs
une fois de ses choix fait les héritages
devrait logiquement en découler et fait
en sorte pour une fois monsieur le
ministre que les éleveurs ne soient pas
les seuls à porter l'effort budgétaire
alors que leur situation ne le permet
pas pouvez vous nous assurez monsieur le
ministre que les zones de polyculture
élevage ne seront pas les sacrifiés de
la future pac
chers collègues dans la suite du débat
la parole est à monsieur julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
le débat d'aujourd'hui portent
effectivement sur une politique
absolument structurantes en matière de
souveraineté en matière de territoire en
matière de développement économique et
d'environnement il s'agit de la
politique agricole commune et au moment
d'aborder ce débat je voudrais d'abord
simplement rappelé le contexte européen
dans lequel se situe cette politique
agricole commune vous l'avez dit
monsieur le sénateur tissot la première
proposition de la commission européenne
en terme de budget de la politique
agricole commune était un budget qui
pour la france n'était absolument pas
acceptable
et c'est à l'initiative de la france à
l'initiative de la france que nous avons
réussi à revenir sur cette proposition
d'octobre 2010 8 de la commission
européenne pour faire en sorte que le
budget de la politique agricole commune
soit en euros courants je ne rentrent
pas dans les débats chief mais peu ou
prou le même que celui de la politique
agricole commune actuelle je vous laisse
imaginer monsieur le sénateur si nous
n'avions pas réussi à faire revenir la
commission sur le premier jet de la
politique agricole commune la teneur des
débats que nous aurions eu ce soir c'est
à dire que nous aurions parlé d'une
politique agricole commune avec un
budget parfois en diminution de -5 à
-15% en fonction des dispositifs dont la
politique agricole commune est constitué
la seconde étape ça a été le contexte
le conseil pardon européen des ministres
de l'agriculture à l'automne dernier qui
nous a permis d'élaborer le cadre
politique de cette politique agricole
commune et notamment avec un élément
très important qui est ce fameux échos
régime et vous l'avez dit là aussi tous
les deux assez tribune c est qu au
régime ils doivent nous permettre de
faire en sorte qu'il s'applique à tous
les états membres sans exception sans
dérogation pour faire en sorte que
enceinte cette convergence dans les
normes et des standards agro
environnementaux y compris au sein du
marché commun souhaite une réalité et
nous avons obtenu gain de cause
reste maintenant à établir ce plan
stratégique national et comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur il faut
absolument veiller à ce que ses plans
stratégiques nationaux ne crée pas assez
t à cette aune des distorsions de
concurrence
mais ils soient bien tous conformes à ce
cadre de la politique agricole commune
les négociations au niveau européen ça
complexifie le débat sont toujours en
cours le tri loeb n'est pas encore
finalisé par exemple les chorégies monde
s'est passé ce sera 20 25 ou 30% du
premier pilier il nous faut faire avec
cette ce thriller probablement devrait
se terminer d'ici la fin du mois de mai
au début du mois de juin en tout cas
sous présidence portugaise mais c'est à
dire qu'il ya déjà quelques avancées qui
ont été actés dont une qui me tenait
particulièrement à coeur et sur laquelle
nous sommes beaucoup battus c'est
l'inclusion du droit à l'erreur au sein
de la politique agricole commune et je
crois que c'est essentiel parce que
combien d'entre vous ont déjà alerté le
ministre que je suis ou mes
prédécesseurs en dix ans il y à un
rappel des paiements de la politique
agricole commune qu'on considère souvent
comme non justifiée tout simplement
parce que le droit à l'erreur n'était
pas inclus dans les fondamentaux de la
politique agricole commune nous avons eu
gain de cause nous avons obtenu cette
inclusion un autre exemple la
prolongation des autorisations
plantations viticole de 2030 à 2045 pour
tous voulaient les grands défenseurs des
territoires viticoles que vous êtes
on sait à quel point c'était une demande
importante pour le secteur mais d'autres
sujets sont encore sur la table je
pensais aller qu'au régime je pense à la
conditionnalité d'un certain nombre de
règles je pense à la rotation des
cultures qui est un sujet sur lequel
nous nous battons
beaucoup je pense à l'organisation
commune des marchés c'est-à-dire des
mécanismes permettant de venir soutenir
en cas de crise émond a vu encore avec
l'épisode dramatique de jeunes ces
dernières semaines et face à cela
quel est notre agenda notre agenda de
finaliser ce plan stratégique national
d'ici la fin de l'année ce qui nécessite
de le finaliser au niveau national d'ici
cet été pour le conclure d'ici la fin de
l'année avec la commission pourquoi
d'ici cet été parce qu'une fois qu'on a
nous finaliser la première version de ce
plan stratégique national il y à des
évaluations environnementales qui
doivent avoir lieu pour y parvenir nous
avons fait déjà beaucoup d'étapes
d'abord l'exercice de diagnostic avec
l'ensemble des filières ensuite la
consultation de débat public que la loi
demande de faire avec plus de 1083
recommandations des citoyens une très
forte participation des citoyens à cet
exercice dont nous avons rendu toutes
les conclusions au mois d'avril dernier
et enfin l'exercice de concertation de
consultation avec l'ensemble des
filières mais également des
organisations civiles notamment les uns
les ong est également très important les
régions parce que vous le savez d'un
thème de la loi dadt que vous avez
adopté ici même il y à un transfert
d'une partie du 2e pilier vers les
régions notamment sur ce qu'on appelle
des les aides non surfacique par exemple
l'aide à l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs et donc toutes ces
concertations sont en cours avec un
calendrier qui aujourd'hui se précise
c'est à dire se resserre au delà de tous
ces éléments de contexte quelle est la
vision que je souhaite porter pour ce
plan stratégique national il ya quatre
axes primordiaux et nous y reviendrons
évidemment dans le débat d'un cadre des
questions réponses
le premier axe c'est une politique
agricole commune qui doit être
compétitive c'est à dire qu'il doit
assurer le revenu des agriculteurs
en tout cas dans ce cas-là d'important
pour le revenu des agriculteurs
et ça ça nécessite quelque chose c'est
une certaine stabilité dans la politique
agricole commune par exemple ne plus
refaire de gros transferts comme avait
eu lieu lors des deux procès d'ante
politique agricole commune et qui par
exemple dans le cadre des zones
intermédiaires monsieur le sénateur
avait conduit à une diminution très
significatif des paiements de base dans
les zones internes
dire parce qu'il y avait eu ce transfert
là alors certains s'en réjouissent et
enfin d'autres notamment dans les zones
intermédiaires ont payé des conséquences
et donc moi je pense qu'il faut une
certaine forme de stabilité entre les
territoires entre les cultures entre les
filières végétales et animales
le deuxième pilier pour moi c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire cette
souveraineté alimentaire elle passe vous
l'avez dit par exemple sur des sujets
aux protéines on y reviendra elle passe
aussi par le sujet de la structuration
sein des filières elle passe aussi par
un certain nombre de revues on y
reviendra également mais dans le cadre
des aides couplées passer à un système
qu'on appelle le système de gouges et b
dont on discute évidemment beaucoup avec
la filière elle passe et ça ne doit
jamais être oublié par agir sur d'autres
piliers que la politique agricole
commune je pense à égalité on en a
beaucoup débattu dans cette haute
assemblée et un nouveau projet de texte
arrivera des mois de juin l'assemblée
nationale puis au sénat
le troisième axe est la transition agro
écologiques sur la base de cet éco
régime et il faut que c'était qu'origine
il soit inclusif une transition agro
écologique c'est une transition qu'il
faut qu'ils soient inclusives pour
accompagner les filières on y re on
pourra y revenir et des demandes dans le
détail ce qui m'importe moi pour l'éco
régime c'est qu'ils soient appliqués par
tous les états membres et qu'il soit
inclusif au sein de nos cultures pour
que ses coutures puissent être
accompagnés dans les transitions et
surtout pas exclue dans les transitions
c'est extrêmement important
et puis le quatrième angle c'est la
prise en compte des territoires des
territoires de montagne des territoires
dans leur spécificité et des zones
intermédiaires
en dehors de ces quatre axes
stratégiques n'oublions jamais que il ne
s'agit pas là d'un débat budgétaire le
débat budgétaire nous avons déjà eu et
c'est la france qui est le gain de cause
et heureusement et je vous remercie
monsieur le sénateur qui soit parce que
vous l'avez dit et je vous en remercie
beaucoup
aujourd'hui il s'agit de répartir cette
enveloppe financière au sein des
différents production des différentes
productions et des différents
territoires donc des comprend qu'elle
des comprend quelque part ou plutôt des
cons mais quelque part ça veut dire
qu'on prend dans un autre endroit donc
dès qu'on dit il faut renforcer tel
secteur ça veut dire que defacto ont
fait un transfert depuis un autre
secteur vers ce secteur là et je crois
qu'il faut qu'on dit tous en tête parce
que à chaque fois qu'on me demande un
plus quelque part où est-ce qu'on ait le
moins et et c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui rend l'exercice
particulièrement complexe pour conclure
je voudrais simplement insister sur deux
derniers points
en dehors du psn il y a vraiment cette
nécessité de continuer à avancer sur la
rémunération des agriculteurs dans le
cadre de la revue de la loi lru la loi
et ghanim a permis des avancées mais
faut aller plus loin et le deuxième
élément je suis intimement convaincu
qu'il faut et je sais que c'est
largement partagée à traverser bon qu'il
faut absolument aller plus loin dans ce
qu'on appelle les clauses miroir c'est à
dire au moment où on s'est beaucoup plus
de transition agro écologique au sein du
marché commun européen et des qu'origine
devient un standard et c'est très bien
ainsi
il faut absolument qu'on sorte d'une
certaine forme d'hypocrisie qui continue
qui consiste à toujours importer des
produits qui ne respectent pas des
propres standards imposés par l'union
européenne et ça ça nécessite pas qu'un
travail au niveau européen que je
mènerai au titre de la présidence
française de l'union européenne mais
aussi un travail à l'international
notamment avec l'om c'est qui guide ces
règles du commerce international
et pour moi c'est absolument essentiel
et j'en fais un marqueur fort de mon
action je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre dans le débat
la parole est à monsieur henri cabanel
pour le groupe rds pour deux minutes
heure merci monsieur le président à
monsieur le ministre
chers collègues après la gelée noir subi
dans la nuit du 8 au 9 avril par un
grand nombre d'exploitations en france
et compte tenu de mes travaux depuis
2016 à ce sujet je n'aborderai qu'un
seul thème celui de l'assurance récolte
la gestion des risques nous en sommes
désormais tous convaincus et centrale
pour l'avenir de notre agriculture
un français des filières se sont engagés
dans des modes de production durables
l'europe via la future pac
conditionnalité des aides avec des
objectifs de verdissement
ce sont des mutations qui répondent à la
demande sociétale et aux enjeux de santé
publique et de protection de
l'environnement
mais encore faut-il accompagner notre
agriculture dans sa résilience
celle ci doit s'appuyer sur plusieurs
solutions l'épargné de précaution les
mesures de stockage
les outils de stabilisation de revenus
et l'assurance récolte cette dernière ne
correspond pas aujourd'hui a besoin de
nos agriculteurs seuls 30 % sont assurés
malgré la mise en place du contrat socle
de nombreuses préconisations ont été
proposés par la profession pour qu'un
maximum d'agriculteurs s'engagent les
réponses restent toujours en suspens car
nous avons conscience de leur impact
financier réformer le calcul de la
moyenne olympique descendre le
déclenchement de 30 à 20 %
passer d'une est aujourd'hui à 65% à 70%
pour la souscription de contrats 24 juin
2011 lors du débat sur la proposition de
résolution de notre groupe rdse
monsieur marc chesneau avait évalué le
surcoût important sur un budget de près
de 2 milliards du second pilier
monsieur le ministre êtes vous prêt à
défendre ses objectifs de la future parc
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur
cabanettes vous évoquez là un sujet
absolument essentiel qui le sujet de
l'assurance récolte aujourd'hui dans le
budget du le budget du 2e pilier
l'assurance récolte aujourd'hui un pas
dans la nouvelle pac il est d'environ
150 millions d'euros et on sait qu'avec
les risques qui s'accumulent le tendance
et doit être améliorée
on a une question c'est qu'on tire pas
le règlement au minibus et vous l'avez
dit dans la le maximum de ses
possibilités c'était qu'on pourrait
passer de 30 à 20% sur la franchise de
65 à 70% dans le mode de subvention et
ce faisant si on finançait à travers la
pac ça voudrait dire faire d'autres
choix sur le 2e pilier je vous le laisse
à votre sagesse sénatoriales c'est li
chn
les mae et le bio et l'assurance récolte
donc si on fait le choix ça veut dire
soit faire un prélèvement du premier
pilier vers le 2e pilier mais dans ce
cas-là quid de l'impact la pac
compétitifs sur les revenus
et si c'est au sein du 2e pilier comment
fait-on donc c'est une sacrée questions
vraiment une sacrée question parce que
vous l'avez dit des enjeux financiers
sont très importants j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup avec mes équipes travailler sur
le sujet moi je pense que
il faut non pas revoir les critères mais
refonder complètement de modèle il ya
très peu d'exemples à l'international où
ça a marché il ya un exemple qui je
pense doit nous inspirer c'est l'exemple
espagnol qui ont été confrontés il ya
plusieurs décennies exactement questions
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui et qui ont mis plusieurs
années à établir un système qui à la fin
est un système avec plusieurs
dispositifs des subventions sur les
primes des poules de correspondances
avec des réassurances derrière il ya
d'autre systèmes sur lequel évidemment
on travaille également tout ça pour dire
qu'il y aura à la fin une architecture a
créé pour repenser complètement le
modèle on est en train d'y travailler et
deuxième élément une question du
financement
et moi ma conviction c'est que le monde
agricole seul ne peut pas financer les
aléas liés au changement climatique
et si on dit que c'est sur la pac en
fait ça revient à dire c'est uniquement
le monde agricole et donc moi je pense
qu'il faut à la fin des fins assumer
aussi si on veut pérenniser le
dispositif une sorte de solidarité
nationale pour venir accompagner le
monde agricole on faire sinon la
difficulté des choix que je vous ai
résumé en début de réponse à votre
question le ministre monsieur cabanel
oui merci monsieur le ministre de votre
réponse je suis bien consciente des
enjeux financiers mais vous savez aussi
l'importance de du plein
que vous allez mettre en place et je
vous en remercie vous avez annoncé dans
l'hérault plus d'un milliard d'euros par
rapport à cette gelée noir exceptionnel
exceptionnelle par son intensité et son
ampleur mais les professionnels
attendent de beaucoup quand même de ce
joueur je le conçois il ya un choix il
faut effectivement avec les budgets
comprennent faire des choix
vous me rassurez dans ce que vous venez
de dire puisque effectivement voulais
qu'il y ait une solidarité plus large
que le monde agricole et je pense que
c'est important
en tout cas et je le sais que vous savez
que vous connaissez comme moi les âges
et comme nous tous ici
mais cette agriculture notre agriculture
a besoin plus que jamais et notamment
dans des circonstances comme on vient de
vivre d'une certaine résilience et qui
passera effectivement par des
propositions que nous attendons vraiment
si chers collègues
la parole est à gérard lahellec pour le
groupe sert ce pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le traité de lisbonne
spécifique la pac a pour but d'assurer
la stabilité des marchés et surtout un
revenu équitable aux agriculteurs je ne
fais que citer là le traité de lisbonne
lui même forcé de constater quand même
que depuis le découplage des aides ces
objectifs ne sont plus remplies or
l'impact demeure un levier
d'accompagnement majeur de l'agriculture
je conçois que l'exercice soit complexe
et je conçois que les aides du premier
pilier soit structurantes pour
l'économie d'un grand nombre
d'exploitations agricoles toutefois de
gif un maraîcher qui exploita nectaire
et emploie cinq salariés perçoit 5000
euros de pâques quand un céréalier qui
exploite cinq mille hectares en percevra
1 million bref on a besoin d'un paiement
plus redistributif plus juste et il
conviendrait donc d'avoir une
distribution plus équitable qui
permettrait une meilleure rémunération
rémunération aussi par exemple dès 52
premier secteur
on voit bien qu'on a besoin donc d'une
politique redistributive
ce qui est vrai pour ceux ci
vrai pour le deuxième pilier il ne
serait pas normal non plus que vous
puissiez vous appuyez sur les
collectivités territoriales et
singulièrement les régions pour définir
la mise en oeuvre d'un certain nombre de
dispositions spécifiques du 2e pilier
je conclus donc en vous disant qu'il
faut obtenir de l'europe de choses le
principe de subsidiarité avec avec la
compagne en la possibilité pour
l'affluence de moduler et de plafonner
elle même ces aides père collègue
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur si
je résume vous dit et je le conçois
vis-à-vis du territoire que veut que
vous représentez même si vous
représentez évidemment tout toute la
nation
mais vis-à-vis du territoire de vos
origines vous dites il faut avoir plus
de paiement redistributif notamment sur
les 52 ha je le conçois je le laisse
monsieur le sénateur ray dont sarrazy
vous dire ce que les agriculteurs on
penserait sur son propre territoire
alors que pourtant vous avez des pensées
et des valeurs qui ne sont pas 6 et si
éloignés l'un de l'autre mais dans les
zones intermédiaires le paiement
redistributif a une conséquence très
importante mais très importante sur le
revenu des agriculteurs là bas voilà et
la difficulté elle est là parce que ce
qui est probablement favorable pour les
agriculteurs de votre territoire ne le
sont pas du tout pour bébé des
agriculteurs d'autres territoires et
notamment dans les zones intermédiaires
le paiement redistributif dans les zones
intermédiaires a fait que le niveau de
rémunération de base ces fameux des pvc
paiement de base sont aujourd'hui dans
les zones intermédiaires inférieur à la
moyenne nationale est très inférieure à
des moyennes dans le reste de l'europe
et ceux qui aujourd'hui disent il faut
faire beaucoup plus de paiement
redistributif par exemple passer de 10 à
20%
mais ont-ils estimé enfin évaluer plutôt
les conséquences dans les zones
intermédiaires et je peux vous dire que
dans les zones intermédiaires
l' approche par l'actif pourquoi
pourquoi moi je suis complètement contre
l' approche par la taille d'une
agriculture parce que mais monsieur le
sénateur vous le dire y est encore mieux
que moi dans une zone intermédiaire
pourquoi on a une grande exploitation
pas parce qu'on est riche parce que la
rentabilité d'un hectare cultivé dans
une zone intermédiaire est tellement
faible qu'il faut beaucoup d'hectares
pour pouvoir en vivre
c'est ça la réalité et donc si au même
moment vous incluez le paiement
redistributif dans les zones
intermédiaires vous aurez une
conséquence dramatique et donc c'est là
où il nous faut trouver un juste
équilibre
c'est là la difficulté parce que moi à
la fin je vois définir définir tous et
équilibre évidemment certains vont dire
que c'est passé de ton dire que ça va
beaucoup trop loin
machel ministre cela elec aux gens tant
les arguments mais il faut tout
simplement être plus juste moi j'observe
que l'allemagne infléchi un peu ses
politiques dans un sens plus
redistributif il arrive qu'on fasse
référence à la politique allemande y
compris dans cette enceinte
donc c'est une mesure de justice à mon
sens ce qui pourrait être mieux défini
et qui pourraient relever de la
compétence des choix politiques de
l'état français leur collègue monsieur
pierre l'eau pour le groupe union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
d'abord je voudrais saluer le travail du
ministre de l'agriculture qui a engagé
une forte concertation qui a conduit
multiples hypothèses c'est vrai qu'il y
a une enveloppe une enveloppe pour
conduire une politique européenne une
politique agricole commune
il faut continuer à se battre pour
infléchir la politique européenne pour
que les pays de cette europe et les
mêmes règles et des marges de manoeuvre
local beaucoup plus réduite sinon la
concurrence déjà l'agriculture française
est soumise à des règles de concurrence
qu'elle a du mal à tenir
monsieur le ministre j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de nous parler des zones
intermédiaires et je sais que vous
accaparer de ce sujet
mais sur ces zones intermédiaires et en
plus le schéma est un peu faussée parce
que à travers les zones intermédiaires
il ya souvent des vignobles par exemple
qui augmente le revenu global des
agriculteurs la situation de
l'agriculture est catastrophique
plus de revenus plus de jeunes qui
veulent s'installer et malheureusement
l'issue de ces terres c'est
l'agrandissement parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution pour les propriétaires
et que d'urgence il faut trouver des
solutions pour les zones intermédiaires
qui en plus sont des zones de
polyculture et d'élevage bovin en partie
de céréales d'autres partis et c'est
vrai que la suppression des zones
défavorisées sur les zones
intermédiaires a été une catastrophe
pour l'élevage je voudrais vous dire
également monsieur le ministre qu'il
faut se battre pour ne pas faire de
furent transposition des règles
françaises
il faut des règles européennes et rien
que des règles européennes
et enfin je voulais vous dire qu'il
fallait même si les calculs sont
forcément un peu compliqué il faut faire
simple pour éviter tous les conflits de
contrôle de contrôle pour les
agriculteurs et même de contrôle pour la
france puisqu'elle a déjà été condamné
parce que eh ben la lisibilité n'était
pas suffisante et les règles n'étaient
pas forcément respectée
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci monsieur le sénateur lourd pour
pour vos mots oui les zones
intermédiaires pour moi est une priorité
et je les dis que j'ai été nommé à ce
poste parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on parle de zone qui concerne
probablement 80 90 mille agriculteurs et
qui effectivement ont vu les deux
dernières politique agricole commune
impact est très largement leurs propres
revenus
la difficulté c'est qu'on part d'un
existant et dans cet existant la demande
de ces zones intermédiaires à juste
titre est d'augmenter la rémunération
mais augmenter la rémunération et ça
prolonge d'ailleurs la discussion
nécessiterait quoi si on voulait
augmenter la rémunération
je parle de la rémunération donc du
premier pilier ça nécessiterait de faire
des transferts massifs au sein du
premier pilier et les seuls transferts
massifs au sein du premier pilier qui
sont possibles c'est entre les aides
couplées et le paiement de base alors là
je me retourne vers les autres
représentants du secteur d'élevage et là
je vous laisse imaginer le débat que
vous allez avoir entre vous et donc il
faut retrouver nous vend un équilibre
bon et sur cet équilibre
il faut avoir en tête dans les zones
intermédiaires au moins deux choses le
premier c'est que le fameux écho origins
que j'évoquais il a une vertu très
intéressante pour les zones
intermédiaires c'est que l'écho régime
il consiste en fait à répartir en de 20
à 30% connais pas encore le chiffre du
premier pilier à l'ensemble des
agriculteurs dès lors qu'ils atteignent
les conditions de l'éco régime
mais cette répartition il le fait sur
quoi sur la base d'un taux moyen à
l'échelle nationale du paiement de base
et comme les zones intermédiaires sont
en moyenne très largement inférieur au
taux moyen national
le fait d'avoir ce système de de
convergence totale si je puis dire va
permettre de redonner un peu d'air aux
zones intermédiaires premier point et
deuxième point je pense que les mae les
fameuses mae
ça fait depuis 2012 qu'on n'a pas réussi
et qu'on n'a pas mis suffisamment
d'argent dm&e sur les zones
intermédiaires et ça je pense que c'est
un énorme défi de cette nouvelle
politique agricole commune
je pourrais parler d'autres sujets aussi
mais je vois que le temps est un parti
mais en tout cas pour moi c'est
évidemment un sujet de très très grande
attention dit monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame gisèle jourda pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicains pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues imputée sur
le second pilier de la pac
li chn représente environ un milliard
cent millions d'euros par an bénéficiant
à un tiers des exploitations françaises
monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes
engagé publiquement à plusieurs reprises
en faveur du maintien à l'état de
l'enveloppé consacrée aux é chn dans la
nouvelle pac
malgré ce le taux de cofinancement
européen proposé par le conseil passe de
75 à 65 %
ce qui veut dire que si ce taux était
définitivement retenue est que la france
décidé de maintenir l'enveloppé actuelle
elle devrait financer sur son budget 10%
supplémentaires soit environ 108
millions d'euros
dans le contexte de la négociation qui
va s'ouvrir demain à enveloppe fermée
que les arbitrages comptez vous faire
pour financer ses 108 millions d'euros
si bien entendu vous comptez le faire
second volet lié aux conséquences de la
sortie du zonage des zones défavorisées
dites simples ayant fait l'objet d'une
révision en 2018 qui eut pour effet
d'exclure 1350 commune de la
cartographie présenté à la commission
européenne par vos prédécesseurs
et ce monsieur le ministre dans des
conditions plus que déplorables au vu
desquelles ils s'étaient fermement
engagés ici à cette tribune part
d'hommes accompagnés par de multiples
mesures les exploitations qui sortait du
dispositif pour époux et éviter l'effet
ciseau qu'en est-il dans l'aude
rien nada li chn la bel et bien disparu
mais aucune des promesses faites n'ont
été tenues quels dispositifs avez vous
prévu pour aider soutenir ces
agriculteurs ces éleveurs qui ne
demandent qu'à vivre dignement de leur
exploitation
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice jourda deux points
très importants d'abord sur le lit chn
donc li chn ça nous emmène sur le 2e
pilier de la pac et ce deuxième pilier
de la pac
il est financé par quoi par le budget
dont on est convenus au niveau européen
et par potentiellement des transferts du
premier pilier vers le 2e pilier mais
qui dit transfert du premier pilier
verbe deuxième pilier dit diminution de
la rémunération de nos agriculteurs
autant vous dire que moi qui prône une
pac compétitive j'y suis pas très fan
favorable et ça veut dire que sur le 2e
pilier qui est composé dé m est très
important parce que ça me permet de
répondre à votre deuxième question
comment on fait pour accompagner
aujourd'hui de manière spécifique
il ya différents points enfin si je
devais en résumé un c
beaucoup les mêmes et donc ça veut dire
qu'on a un première en jeu c'est
maintenir le niveau des mm deuxièmement
je sais maintenir le niveau de 10 est
chaîne troisième enjeu c'est la question
de l'assurance récolte confirme monsieur
cabanel le sénateur cabane est 4e en jeu
c'est la bio c'est les quatre principaux
enjeux du 2e pilier et si on veut
maintenir des ambitions il faut que
l'état sur le budget national
effectivement n'apporte pas 108 mais
même 140 millions d'euros et donc au
moment où on négocie cette pac
il ya aussi des choix budgétaires il va
nous falloir faire parce que si on veut
maintenir l'ambition d'impact sur le 2e
pilier
il faut que la france sur son budget
national abondent à hauteur de 140
millions d'euros supplémentaires le
deuxième pilier pour maintenir les
ambitions du 2e pilier
voilà et ça c'est les discussions que
nous avons au sein du gouvernement en ce
moment et pour moi il faut une très
grosse ambition sur ce deuxième pilier
donc tout ça est en cours de discussion
mais il faut avoir en tête que ce dont
on parle nécessitant plus un effort
supplémentaire de l'état à hauteur de
140 millions d'euros sur le deuxième
pilier
cette ça montre toute l'ambition qui est
la nôtre mais aussi toute la tâche très
importante parce que c'est la seule
condition pour laquelle on peut avoir
une ambition bio maintenir les mae
maintenir l'iss et à chaîne et maintenir
le tendancielle de l'assurance récolte
voilà dont on parle on mesure la taille
ses 140 millions d'euros par an
ça veut dire 700 millions d'euros sur la
période et monsieur le ministre madame
jour là oui monsieur le ministre
j'entends vos propos mais ce que je
souhaite dire je voulais dit quand vous
êtes venu dans l'aude je crois que
lorsqu'on fait certain effet d'annonce
et lorsqu on promet à nos agriculteurs
de les accompagner lorsqu'il y a des
coups rudes comme une sortie d'une
cartographie ou comme parce qu'ils font
face à des risques naturels
je pense qu'il faut avoir à mon sens le
respect de la parole donnée et là je
compte vraiment que d accompagnement
soit au rendez-vous pour atténuer le
drame que vivent ces éleveurs et
agriculteurs qui ne peuvent plus vivre
et pour vous surtout pour les jeunes qui
sont touchés et qu'ils avaient ainsi
investi sur des secteurs vraiment
défavorisés merci cher collègue monsieur
jean françois rapin pour l'europe les
républicains pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre depuis sa présentation le 1er
juin 2018 le projet de réforme de la
commission européenne pour la politique
agricole commune a nourri de difficile
échanges au sein du conseil du parlement
européen le sénat effectué pour sa part
un important travail de réflexion et de
propositions iii résolution européenne
ont été d'adopter en 2017 2018 et 2019
et de dernier en séance publique et à
l'unanimité au delà de la question de la
stabilité des moyens budgétaires
nous nous sommes vivement inquiété de l'
architecture générale du projet de la
commission européenne à savoir de
l'impact du nouveau mode décentralisé de
la mise en oeuvre de la pac
décentraliser la pac c'est prendre le
risque de distorsion de concurrence
supplémentaire au sein du marché unique
le sénat y voit un réel danger de
remplacement de la pac par 27 politiques
agricoles nationales dans chacun des
états membres
désormais de moins en moins compatibles
entre elles en dernière analyse nous
courons le risque d'une descente d'une
déconstruction de la pac
or sur tous ces points essentiels la
position de la commission européenne n'a
pour ainsi dire jamais changé d'un iota
époux et vos prédécesseurs depuis 2010
est monsieur le ministre n'ont pas agi à
temps et efficacement pour faire bouger
les lignes
cette réforme ne correspondra donc guère
aux voeux du sénat ni aux besoins de nos
agriculteurs dont l'inquiétude va
croissant
reste désormais à clarifier un problème
de fond celui de l'articulation entre
les modalités détaillées de la future
pac et la transcription juridique des
objectifs affichés dans la transition
verte
jean vient infirmer de questions qui
sont liées qu'en est il de la
publication par la commission européenne
de ses études d'impact sur les
stratégies biodiversité et fourchette à
la table et de ferme à la table pardon
comment selon vous à articuler la
réforme de la pac et le green deal si
l'on veut éviter un recul drastique de
la production agricole européenne à
l'horizon 2030 que le ministère
américain de l'agriculture évalue pour
sa part à 12% et ensuite de taille cette
question elle aussi face à une
perspective de décroissance d'une telle
ampleur de nos productions nationales
que deviendraient l'objectif de
souveraineté alimentaire merci cher
collègue monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur rapin plusieurs points d'abord
le jeu vous trouve sévère dans votre
analyse sur la régionalisation de la pac
pour deux points parce que le cadre
politique de la pax et les ministres qui
n'ont défini et le cadre politique on a
défini en octobre il est très précis
mais alors vraiment il est très précis
il vous donne un exemple l'écho régime
ce fameux échos régime le cadre défini
l'imposa tous les états membres et
empêche les effets d'éviction les
dérogations et ça c'est très clair
le deuxième élément c'est que moi je me
bats beaucoup j'ai pas encore eu gain de
cause mais je me bats beaucoup pour que
les fameux plans stratégiques nationaux
ne soit pas simplement signé dans des
bureaux entre les états membres et la
commission
mais soit présenté au niveau du conseil
des ministres parce que je considère que
se prend un plan stratégique national
c'est un document politique où tous les
états membres tous les ministres des
états membres doivent pouvoir en avoir
connaissance et discuter dans l'enceinte
deuxième élément sur vos deux questions
le l'étude d'impact on l'a toujours pas
je peux vous dire qu'on est plusieurs
ministres au niveau européen à ne cesser
de demander la réalisation de cette
étude d'impact parce que c'est un énorme
problème de ne toujours pas déposé
disposer de cette étude d'impact qui
plus est d'un pur
d'une pure signal démocratique on parle
de quelque chose dont la seule étude
d'impact aujourd'hui fait je parle de la
stratégie ferme tout forte et
américaines c'est absolument pas
acceptable
donc on est plusieurs états membres à
suivre de très près la chose pour qu'on
puisse enfin disposer de notre propre
étude d'impact premier prend deuxième
point il faut faire attention
la stratégie form to work est très
différente de la pac c'est la stratégie
ferme et au flop
elle donne des ambitions les conditions
celles attaque mais la femme to fork ce
sont des ambitions c'est très différent
et ce qui minimise d'ailleurs les
conséquences de votre faim de prendre
précédent enfin dernier élément sur le
green deal cette fois-ci moi je fais
partie de ceux qui considèrent que la
pac est un des éléments de ce green deal
mais si d'un côté on fait tout ce qu'on
est en train de faire sur la pac et de
l'autre côté la filière commerce le
fameux trade ne suis pas là c'est raté
et donc moi je me bats beaucoup avec mes
collègues notamment franck ribéry veut
tellement bonnes pour dire à partir du
moment où on s'est tous mis d'accord
sont en écho origins qui des standards
de base dans la filière agricole il faut
que ça se sache qu ils soient
transposées dans la filiale commerce
pour faire gagner de demain ils ne
puissent plus y avoir d'accord sans ce
même socle et donc lutter contre ces
distorsions de concurrence à l'échelle
internationale merci la parole est à
monsieur alain marc pour l'europe les
indépendants pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le violent
épisode de gel que nous agriculteurs
vivent viennent alourdir d emmener
compliqué je tiens à nouveau à leur
apporter tout mon soutien et a salué
leur courage en aviron l'arboriculture a
été touché les annonces notamment la
création d'un fonds de solidarité
exceptionnel doté d'un milliard d'euros
sont des nouvelles rassurantes tout à
l'heure mon collègue kaman elle l'a
indiqué les enjeux restent nombreux le
changement climatique la pandémie de
kovy 19 les défis d'une souveraineté
d'alimentation et bien d'autres
l'agriculture est depuis toujours
synonyme d'adaptation je pourrais faire
remonter les craintes de nos
agriculteurs des zones très rurales au
sujet de la future pac les exploitations
qui sont de taille moyenne voire petit
leur modèle est souvent orientés vers
les lobes l'élevage je rappelle que la
veyron est le premier département au 22
francs
c est un des tout premiers au niveau
bovins et une agriculture exigeante qui
demande un travail durant les 365 jours
de l'année les aides directes du premier
pilier de la pac sont dans ces
territoires d'une importance capitale
il faut bien sûr faire des ajustements
nous comprenons les appels à l'évolution
du système assurantiel dans le second
pilier
mais nous redoutons le transfert depuis
le premier pilier qui en découlent
il a pour conséquence la baisse des
aides et impacts de plein fouet nos
petites fermes cela pourrait provoquer
de nouvelles étapes dans l'exode rural
que nous subissons déjà malgré les
efforts considérables que font nos
maires ruraux
monsieur le ministre alors que vous
plancher sur le plan stratégique
national
quelles sont vos pistes concernant les
vases communicants entre le 1er et 2e
pilier et plus précisément au sujet de
l'évolution du taux de transfert du
premier pilier vers le second dans la
future pac et monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur
comme je disais pour moi il ya quatre
maîtres mots dans la nouvelle politique
agricole commune une politique agricole
commune compétitif c'est à dire de
production une politique agricole
commune qui tient compte des
spécificités des territoires une
politique agricole commune qui a
accompagné le mot très important des
transitions notamment agro écologiques
et une politique agricole commune qui
nous permettent de regagner en
souveraineté alimentaire une fois que
j'ai 2 10 ces quatre objectifs
on voit bien que cela n'est possible que
si j'arrive à stabiliser le premier
pilier
parce que ce premier pilier et la
rémunération on en a beaucoup parlé lors
des différentes première prise de parole
et que au même moment si on veut faire
l'accompagnement du 2e pilier comme je
le disais à madame la sénatrice ça
nécessite que l'état viennent abonder à
hauteur de 140 millions d'euros
le deuxième pilier par an pendant cinq
ans soit 700 millions d'euros et donc
tous les arbitrages qui sont en cours et
des négociations et les discussions qui
sont en cours avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes montre l'ampleur du
défi et ça c'est sans parler de la
refonte de l'assurance récolte que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure en réponse à
monsieur le sénateur cabanel est encore
une fois pour moi est un sujet qui a
intrinsèquement liées à la pac parce que
relève du règlement ni bus mais qui j'en
ai la conviction ne peut pas être traité
uniquement
sans de la pac parce que si on faisait
ça ça voudrait dire qu'on serait obligé
d'opérer un transfert massif du premier
pilier vers le 2e ou de réduire li chn
ou de réduire les mae significativement
ou de réduire l'ambition bio ou de
réduire
un défunt le deuxième pilier de manière
générale s'il n'y a pas un transfert du
premier vers le deuxième bref je pense
que cette assurance récolte on doit
admettre le fait que le monde agricole à
l'aune de ses propres budgets ou du
budget de la pac n'est pas à même de
seul faire face aux aléas du changement
climatique d'où la proposition de
refonte du système
merci alain marc monsieur le ministre en
termes d'aménagement du territoire nous
avons la chance en france d'avoir un
territoire extrêmement mallet il y à des
fermes partout des agriculteurs partout
sur notre territoire national certaines
fermes et certains agriculteurs gagnent
très peu leur vie ils ont pour beaucoup
d'entre eux moins de 1000 euros par mois
donc je vous demande bien évidemment à
travers ce pack de bien regarder cela et
puis je vous réitère mon invitation de
venir en aveyron nous vous recevrons de
façon forte amical et nous vous
exprimons ici et là nos problématiques
merci monsieur le ministre
merci chers collègues la parole est à
joël labbé pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire pour deux minutes
était belle l'ambition bio de la france
impulsée par stéphane le foll
d'atteindre 15% de s a eu en 2022 vous
l'avez annoncé vous même il ya une
dizaine de jours la france n'atteindra
pas ses objectifs et je dirais même bien
loin de là il en va demain très
vraisemblablement pour l'objectif
d'intégration de 20 % de produits bio
dans la restauration collective votée
par la loi et galim et pourtant malgré
ces échecs le gouvernement continue de
baisser l'accompagnement financier à
cette agriculture
après la fin du financement national de
l'aide au maintien
c'est aujourd'hui la réforme de la pac
qui a un nouveau recul alors que la
performance économique social et
environnemental de l'agriculture
biologique est établie alors que la
demande des consommateurs pour des
produits biologiques ne cesse de croître
alors que l'urgence écologique est
toujours plus prégnante
la première proposition du plan national
stratégique montre que la bio sera la
grande perdante de cette politique
d'après les chiffres qui sont sur la
table des négociations alors que dans la
pac actuelle un agriculteur bio touche
est en moyenne 202 euros dead
environnementale par
tha ils ne seraient rémunérés dans la
prochaine programmation qu'à hauteur de
70 euros soit une baisse de 66%
comment vous expliquez monsieur le
ministre une telle diminution du soutien
au maintien en agriculture biologique
alors même que la rémunération des
services environnementaux faisait partie
des engagements présidentiels
certes il est important il est essentiel
d'accompagner toutes les agricultures
tous les agriculteurs dans la tronche
dans la transition et pas seulement la
bio mais pour autant monsieur le
ministre comment justifier de ce coup de
frein sur l'agriculture biologique
allez-vous proposer un cercle à un
scénario alternatif permettant
d'atteindre des objectifs de la france
et de rémunérer ce système à la hauteur
de ses performances conjuguées
d'économie et d'écologie pour toi merci
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
le sénateur l'abbé deux points d'abord
sur le sur le contexte effectivement
notre objectif c'était 15 % de bio en
2022 je pense qu'on finira douze ennemis
ou 13%
on peut dire que c'est passé d'ailleurs
je suis le premier puisque c'est
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixé cette es15
enfin c'est quand même une augmentation
de 50% par rapport à 2010 7 ans et je
dis bien une augmentation de 50% par
rapport à 2010 est alors après on peut
dire que c'est pas assez
enfin on peut pas non plus
être dans une critique excessive et plus
je dis pas que c'est ça que vous faites
mais mais parfois j'entends ici là on
aura on sera quand même un gouvernement
qui aura augmenté de 50% la surface
agricole utile en bio dans notre pays en
l'espace de cinq ans je pense qu'on n'a
pas à en rougir
s'agissant des écoles ça vous aura pas
échappé c'est pas moi qui passe les
commandes dans les écoles mais ça ça
vous aura pas échappé mais je sais à qui
vous le vous devez le dire et je sais
que vous leur dites au niveau local
puisque s'est passé au niveau local le
troisième élément sur la pac
j'ai vu aussi mais alors avec grand
étonnement ce chiffre de -1 66%
parce que ce que ne disent pas ce c'est
il ya un différend en fait c'est sur la
question de l'aide au maintien ça mais
on a déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler
souvent dans cet hémicycle de dire
faut-il ou pas faire de l'aide au
maintien plutôt que de l'aide bio mais
sur d'autres dispositifs que l'aide au
maintien
il s'avère que les mêmes scénarii mais
ça personne ne le dit qu'ils ont été mis
sur la table dans le cadre de la
consultation il dise quoi ils disent que
l' enveloppe de financement bio passe de
250 millions d'euros à 340 millions
d'euros de 250 à 340 millions d'euros
et ça s'est transformé en dix ans le
gouvernement propose -66% dead parfois
il ya des chiffres un peu magique que
certains savent utiliser mieux que
d'autres
merci monsieur l'abbé oui sur les
grandes masses mais il y a il y à un
développement extraordinaire de
l'agriculture biologique vous ne pouvez
pas le nier
et elle doit encore être être accéléré
la tension au revenu des agriculteurs
est absolument louable est nécessaire
mais beaucoup d'agriculteurs reste aussi
oublié de la pâte je pense aux petites
fermes aux maraîchers aux arboriculteurs
aux paysans herboriste qui sont en marge
et non pris en considération alors que
la résilience l'emploi le respect de
l'environnement il a sion merci chers
collègues
la parole est à madame patricia sheen
âgé pour le groupe air des pays pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur min
pour notre pays qui occupe la première
place de l'union européenne en matière
agricole
l'agriculture est un secteur stratégique
ce secteur est aujourd'hui au carrefour
de nombreux enjeux en plus de devoir
assurer la souveraineté alimentaire de
notre pays il doit répondre à une
exigence croissante de qualité il s'agit
aussi pour la profession de s'orienter
vers une agriculture plus durable
respectueuse de l'environnement et
soucieuse du climat répondre à ces
enjeux nécessitent de la part des
agriculteurs qui réalise de gros efforts
allant même qu'ils sont déjà soumis à de
nombreuses contraintes telles que la
multiplication des aléas climatiques ou
encore la volatilité des prix
dans ce contexte les négociations en
cours concernant la pac constitue un
enjeu de taille pour notre pays et ses
agriculteurs
à ce titre nous savons tous que vous
n'avez pas ménager vos efforts pour
placer la france au coeur des enjeux
européens ce qui a permis à la pac de
demeurer le premier budget européen et à
notre pays de conserver l'enveloppent
qui lui était alloué ces aides de la pac
sans lesquels beaucoup d'agriculteurs
aurait des revenus négatifs doivent les
encourager sur le chemin de ceux de
cette mutation les contours encore flous
de cette nouvelle pac suscite toutefois
des inquiétudes chez les agriculteurs
ils craignent notamment qu'une mise en
oeuvre différencier des objectifs de la
pac au travers des plans stratégiques
nationaux n'aboutisse à des situations
de distorsions de concurrence entre les
états membres
ils se soucient également des critères
d'accès aux échos régime qui se doivent
d'être le plus inclusif et incitatif
possible comment entendez vous répondre
à ces inquiétudes et plus largement
préserver la compétitivité et la
rentabilité de notre agriculture tout en
encourageant sa mutation vers un modèle
plus durable et plus raisonnée
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice jeunes âgés de deux
éléments de réponses d'abord le premier
c'est vrai que
l'écho régime a une caractéristique sur
laquelle nous nous sommes beaucoup
battus c'est que cet éco régime il est
obligatoire pour tous les états membres
et ça je crois que c'est essentiel parce
que ça concourt véritablement à arrêter
cette spirale de concurrence déloyale au
sein même du marché commun et il n'y a
rien de plus à la fois de décourageant
et désespérant que de se retrouver avec
deux produits issus de deux lieux de
production de différents sein de
l'europe et sur le même marché commun
qui ne répondent pas aux mêmes normes de
production et donc les corps régime va
enfin pouvoir permettre de d'inverser
cette tendance est de remettre de la
concurrence loyale dans tous les choses
sur ce marché commun puisqu'il
s'imposera à tous les états mans
le deuxième élément sur cette éco régime
et c'est le deuxième sens de votre
question c'est que c'est l'élément de
transition agro écologique de cette
nouvelle politique agricole commune mais
j'insiste dessus il doit être inclusif
il doit permettre d'accompagner les
agriculteurs si c'est un dispositif qui
nous permet pas une accessibilité de la
part des agriculteurs on fera pas de
transition faire une transition sans les
agriculteurs ça ne revient pas à faire
une transition et donc il nous faut
vraiment trouver les voies et moyens
pour que cet éco régime accompagne soit
inclusif et surtout pas exclusif et la
réponse à votre question est d'arriver à
trouver ce bon équilibre justement si
monsieur mélismes chine un jeune
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
venant d'un territoire frontalier
l'alsace je tenais encore a insisté sur
les inquiétudes en termes de concurrence
que pourraient engendrer les mesures de
la future pac le risque de concurrence
déloyale existent à l'intérieur des
frontières de l'union
mais aussi aux portes de l'union
européenne aussi nous comptons sur vous
avec l'europe pour veiller à ce que les
importations extra-européennes répondent
à des exigences qui soit au moins
équivalente à celle que nous imposons à
nos agriculteurs
il en va de la survie de notre
agriculture merci monsieur philippe
folliot pour l'union centriste pour deux
minutes hommes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
il s'appelle pascal sébastien joël
claude françoise uriel ils sont là
agricultrices et agriculteurs de nos
zones de montagne du massif central du
sud du massif central
et aujourd'hui c'est un véritable cri
d'un gosse de désespérance qui est le
leur face à la situation qu'ils vivent
une situation sans précédent
ils étaient les agricultrices
agriculteurs en zone de montagne 105000
en 1995 75000 en 2005 moins de 70 milles
aujourd'hui avec cette des prises qui
concerne cette l'agriculture de montagne
c'est une situation qui est une
situation difficile et qu'il jugeait
injuste parce que l'agriculture de
montagne et d'élevage et plus
respectueuse de l'environnement avec
moins de densité
elle est aussi souvent avec des produits
de qualité
et pourtant lundi dernier au marché de
valence d'albigeois les veaux se sont
vendues au même prix qu'il ya 30 ans
c'est tout juste inacceptables et que
par rapport à cette situation
monsieur le ministre il y à une attente
une atteinte particulièrement forte donc
de nos agriculteurs
une de nos éleveurs une attente qui
consiste un tout d'abord avoir un
maintien de liesse à chaîne ensuite
d'avoir des mesures d'accompagnement
pour favoriser l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs pour stopper cette
véritable hémorragie
sur l'ensemble de ces éléments
pouvez-vous nous rassurer monsieur le
ministre sur les perspectives qui
pourrait y avoir un moyen terme pour
cette agriculture
monsieur le ministre si beaucoup
monsieur le président merci beaucoup
monsieur le sénateur pour l'hommage que
vous avez rendu à
à nos éleveurs et qui font partie de
cette souveraineté alimentaire de notre
pays et plus je dirais à cette identité
de beaucoup de nos territoires qui au
final additionnez constitue notre beau
pays france sur la question de la
rémunération vous avez évoqué 10 chn j'y
reviens pas on a beaucoup parlé tout à
l'heure il faut juste avoir encore une
fois en tête que pour maintenir
l'ensemble de ces éléments du 2e pilier
il faut que le budget national apporte
une solidarité supplémentaire au titre
de la pac à hauteur de 140 millions
d'euros par an pendant cinq ans soit 700
millions d'euros donc maintenir tout ce
deuxième pilier nécessite de faire cela
ce qui témoignerait du fort
accompagnement de l'état en termes de
choix stratégique vis-à-vis de notre
agriculture et singulièrement sur ces
mécanismes d'accompagnement mae de
financement et ses chaînes de bio ou
d'assurance récolte qui sont des quatre
composantes du 2e pilier
le deuxième élément c'est les aides
couplées sur les aides couplées beaucoup
a été dit et c'est moi j'ai une
conviction mais qui est partagée assez
largement c'est la pertinence de passer
à un modèle dit de lui gb alors après le
diable se niche dans les détails c'est à
dire que une fois qu'on a dit ça il ya
beaucoup de deux critères de paramètres
qu'il nous faut bien définir et donc ça
c'est d'importants travaux qui sont en
cours
et enfin le troisième élément c'est
évidemment l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs vous l'avez dit alors
l'installation elle peut relever du
premier pilier sur des dispositifs
elle va relever aussi du 2e pilier et
dans le 2e pilier elle relèvera
dorénavant des régions c'est très
important que vous l'ayez en tête
chacune et chacun parce que c'est aussi
des débats qu'on devra avoir avec les
régions sur ce qu'on appelle la dg à la
dotation jeune agriculteur
enfin et vous l'avez dit la question de
la rémunération sur les marchés ou
autres relève de tous les travaux que
nous avons entrepris en remettant le
métier sur l'ouvragé avec la loi et
ghenim de cette fameuse bpr dessau
moraux que nous aurons je l'espère
l'occasion de discuter très rapidement
dans cette haute assemblée
parce que je pense que les gars limite
est une avancée mais ghenim 2 doit aller
au bout pour enfin améliorer la
rétribution cour de ferme
philippe folliot merci monsieur le
ministre c'est vrai que c'était un
élément particulièrement important que
vous nous dites mais sachez que ce cri
du coeur étonne cris vraiment de
désespérance et que dans ce cadre là
tout se tient dans nos secteurs de
montagne et de ruralité c'est le jour il
n'ya plus l'élevage et l'agriculture
c'est tout le reste qui s'effondre avec
tous les emplois induits par rapport à
cela ce sont les services publics qui
sont un jeu derrière et que donc à ce
niveau là nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
dans nos secteurs de montagne que
l'élevage pour des raisons qui sont des
raisons physiques et que donc dans ce
cadre à nous avons un besoin un besoin
essentiel d'être soutenus et appuyés
dans le cadre d' une juste compensation
des handicaps naturels merci merci chers
collègues
la parole est à jean jacques michau pour
le groupe socialistes et communistes
républicains pour deux minutes heure
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
vous me disiez le 7 avril dernier aux
ici au sénat que le soutien à une
agriculture de territoires de montagne
avec une meilleure prise en compte des
spécificités et le maintien des 10 ch n
était une des priorités de la nouvelle
pac
élue d'un territoire de montagne je ne
peux que construite que sus que
souscrire à cette volonté qui permet de
maintenir un mariage d'actifs agricoles
et une présence humaine dans ces
territoires
c'est le plus
sur moyenne d'empêcher l'abandon des
terres et leurs conséquences négatives
en terme de paysage de biodiversité
ainsi que de développement notamment
touristiques la pac 2023 à 2029
introduira une nouvelle innovation de
gouvernance il s'agit des psn qui
renvoie chaque état membre le soin de
définir les modalités de mise en oeuvre
de la pac à l'échelle nationale vous
aurez donc monsieur le ministre a décidé
du soutien que vous accorderez à
l'agriculture de montagne
bruxelles a d'ores et déjà annoncé une
baisse de 10% de l' enveloppe de saisie
chn alors monsieur le ministre l'état
français abondent aura-t-il de 10%
l'enveloppent consacré aux é chn pour
consacrer la baisse européenne annoncée
j'ai entendu que vous vous engagiez
hauteur de 140 millions par an j'espère
que cette promesse sera bien tenue
pouvez vous aussi nous confirmer que les
surcoûts des exploitations de montagne
liées au handicap continueront d'être
compensés au moins à leur niveau actuel
à travers unis chn forte et qui ne
subira pas de baisse ainsi qu'en est-il
de prod2 possible extension à certaines
productions végétales en fait monsieur
le ministre si nous appelons de nos
voeux une meilleure gestion est prise en
charge des risques climatiques
il faudrait pas non plus que de
nouvelles mesures viennent diminuer les
aides existantes
je vous remercie si monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur sur le volet ils s'achètent
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'y répondre à
plusieurs reprises jeu
aujourd'hui on est en train de finaliser
donc tout c'est cet équilibre puisque
disais tout à l'heure il s'agit de
trouver le bon équilibre la négociation
budgétaire ayant déjà eu lieu et je
pense qu'on peut que l'événement s'en
satisfaire puisque grâce à véritablement
la france est singulièrement le
président la république ça s'est joué à
ce niveau là on a réussi à maintenir des
budgets conséquents et qu'aujourd'hui
dans cette répartition encore une fois
sur le volet ils ces chaînes et 2e
pilier si on veut maintenir toutes ses
ambitions il nous faut abondé à hauteur
de 140 millions d'euros le deuxième
pilier par des crédits nationaux donc
toute l' architecture qu'on sortira
confiné nécessite cela sauf sinon à
faire des transferts entre le premier
pilier le deuxième pilier qu'il a et si
vous retournez à vos collègues à
proximité notamment juste derrière vous
à droite
à mon avis il le prendrait mal parce que
c'est un pacte aurait énormément un
certain nombre de cultures dans sur son
territoire donc c'est ma vision et c'est
ce sur quoi je me bats et on est en
train d'avoir toutes ces discussions
mais c'est la vision très claire que
j'ai d'allier à la fois une pac
compétitive de production et une pac qui
prend en compte les spécificités des
territoires je peux pas être plus clair
le deuxième élément sur l'assurance
récolte vous l'avez dit moi je pense que
c'est pas tant une question d'assurance
récolte versus des normes c'est pour
reprendre les propos de certains de vos
collègues c'est qu'aujourd'hui mettons
nous à la place d'un jeune agriculteur
comment vous allez vous installer si
vous avez une épée de damoclès au-dessus
de la tête en vous disant peut-être que
dans les deux trois quatre prochaines
années une année sur deux vous avez un
risque de perte ou de votre récolte
comme ça a été le cas malheureusement
dans le territoire que vous représentez
dernièrement sur le gel s'il n'y a pas
un filet de sécurité qu'on arrive à
apporter ça va être très compliqué de
convaincre la jeune génération de
s'installer alors que 50 % des
agriculteurs partent à la retraite dans
les cinq à sept prochaines années
donc c'est une question de souveraineté
de réussir à refonder le modèle de
l'assurance récolte c'est un sacré
chantier mais je peux vous dire que ça
fait des mois et des mois conciliateur
et j'espère bien y parvenir
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
michaud istres juste ne sacrifiez pas
l'agriculture de montagne
merci la parole à madame vivette lopez
pour l'europe les républicains pour deux
minutes
merci le sait le président le seul
ministre et chers collègues aux yeux des
français des principaux concernés eux
mêmes les agriculteurs la pac reste
complexe mal comprise pourtant chacun
s'accorde à dire combien les nécessaires
pour répondre aux enjeux complémentaires
et parfois contradictoires qui
permettent d'assurer notre sécurité
alimentaire tout en renforçant les
actions favorables à l'environnement
mais aussi au tissu socio économique des
zones rurales
à cet égard une évidence se fait jour la
france doit effectuer des propositions
qui vont dans le sens de la
simplification avant dans la pac plus
accessible et plus lisible
dans cette perspective elle doit elle se
doit de construire l' architecture des
places stratégiques nationaux autour de
celui qui fait l'agriculteur
l'agriculture pardon l'agriculteur ces
agriculteurs qui doivent être au centre
de nos préoccupations pour redonner du
bon sens aux politiques européennes
il convient en effet de tenir compte que
l'agriculteur qui sont entrepreneurs ou
paysan est un professionnel qui produit
qui aménageait le territoire avec des
approches et des pratiques différentes
et qui sut doit être accompagné dans la
réalité de son métier pour percevoir une
juste rémunération
il avait hâte de la reconnaissance de la
valeur travail mais aussi du nécessaire
renouveau le renouvellement des
générations
on regarde l'évolution du métier du
revenu de la main d'oeuvre occupé sur
l'exploitation de l'objet social on
regarde ce qu'ils exercent et non
seulement une véritable activité
agricole mais aussi des activités dans
l'agricole en dehors de la grèce
plantations ont regardé spécificités
des surfaces et les territoires et je
pense là aux zones de châtaigneraies de
cheminée ou encore des zones humides de
camargue dans le département du gard qui
sont encore soumises à dérogations
pourrions nous définir afin de le
protéger
un statut de l'agriculteur et pouvons
nous compter sur vous monsieur le
ministre pour porter l'exigence de cette
clarification est intégré cette question
dans les prochaines échéances
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice vous évoquez un
sujet qui est très important et qui en
fait à deux spécificités parce qu'on
parle d' actifs et d'agriculteurs
véritable alors en fait ces deux sujets
très différents et je vous d'ailleurs
vous avez pas du tout confondu les deux
mais je le dis parce que dans les débats
c'est souvent de deux sujets qui parfois
sont assimilés alors qu'ils sont
extrêmement différents et un premier
sujet au niveau européen qui la question
de l'actif sarko aujourd'hui des aides
de la politique agricole commune elles
sont fondées sur les hectares et non pas
des actifs sur les hectares d
exploitation et non pas le nombre de
personnes qui y travaillent et tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs y avait nos questions
en ce sens de monsieur le sénateur en
dix ans ne faut-il pas revenir sur un
système à l'actif plutôt qu'un système à
l'hectare et là il faut qu'on soit très
clair dessus si on faisait ça
aujourd'hui ce serait très
contraignant c'est pas le bon terme la
france y perdrait beaucoup je veux dire
comme ça pourquoi parce que évidemment
toutes choses égales par ailleurs il ya
plus d'actifs dans certains pays de
l'union européenne qu'en france avec y
compris des sujets de niveaux salariaux
qui ont rien à voir
et donc si la répartition des aides au
niveau de la poche globale de la
politique agricole commune se faisait
sur le nombre d'actifs en fait la somme
totale dont la france aurait aujourd'hui
le bénéfice est fait l'objet de la
répartition serait bien inférieur à ce
que nous avons parce que notamment on ne
sait jamais mis d'accord au niveau
européen sur la définition d'actifs et
donc moi je dis attention je comprends
que certains veulent avancer sur ce
sujet m'enfin si c'est pour avoir comme
conséquence de réduire l'enveloppé
globale que la france perçoit de la pac
je pense que personne n'y a intérêt il
tant que ça veut dire qu'il faut avancer
au niveau européen sur cette définition
d'actifs en tenant compte des
spécificités des uns et des autres en
revanche qu'un deuxième sujet qui est
cette fois-ci l'agriculteur véritable
est ce à ce sujet de l'agriculteur
véritable moi j'ai toujours dit c'est
notamment beaucoup poussé par les jeunes
agriculteurs que j'étais prêt à ouvrir
ce sujet là ça n'est pas inclus à
proprement parler dans les maquettes
financière donc on a un peu de temps
pour le faire donc une fois qu'on s'est
mis d'accord sur tout les répartitions
travaillons sur ce sujet de
l'agriculteur véritable pour notamment
éviter les cas que vous avez évoquées
dans votre question moi je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce qu'on travaille sur
le sujet de l'agriculteur véritale mais
qui est très différent du sujet de
l'actif messieurs ministre à dame lopez
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse est tout comme mon collègue
allaient marque
je vous renouvelle mon invitation à
venir déguster les produits locaux de
nos agriculteurs gardois
merci cher collègue madame florence
blatrix compta pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicain monsieur le
président monsieur le ministère
collègues les crises sanitaires et les
dérèglements climatiques mettent en
évidence la nécessité de repenser nos
modèles économiques et de développement
construire des circuits courts économes
en énergie de la production à l'assiette
du consommateur élaborer des process de
qualité entretenir
et améliorer chaque jour le cadre
naturel et environnemental tels sont là
aujourd'hui les principaux axes de tous
les états membres de l'ue alors où nous
discutons de la pac
le modèle d'exploitation de l'école
française s'est construit à partir
d'unités de production de taille modeste
souvent familiales et transmises sur
plusieurs générations
et alors que beaucoup d paces pensait ce
modèle dépassé au profit de plus grande
unité
ce modèle retrouve aujourd'hui sa
pertinence dans cette mutation
nécessaire pour un véritable green deal
pourtant ce modèle subi une érosion
démographique très forte qui menacent
son existence même est l'enjeu de la
réforme de la pac et du psn qui
l'accompagnent nous semble aussi être
l'affirmation de ce modèle économique
qui a démontré sa grande résilience
nous souhaitons ou aujourd'hui nous
assurer que ce sont bien aussi vos
ambitions
donc dans ce contexte et dans le dédale
complexe de la pac et du futur psn
comment entendez vous concrètement
favoriser les exploitations petites et
moyennes et favoriser l'emploi en leur
sein et par quels mécanismes j'ai bien
entendu vos réticences sur les aides à
l'actif mais ce sujet doit néanmoins
être à mon avis étudiez vos réticences
aussi sur les majorations des de l'aide
aux premiers hectares qui risquerait de
pénaliser les zones intermédiaires mais
quels équilibres trouvés pour favoriser
ces petites ces petites installations
merci monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup
en fait la grande difficulté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la si je puis me
permettre à mme la sénatrice vous dites
que le modèle français est fondé sur des
petites et moyennes exploitations
c'est très frais l'échelle européenne
vous prenez y compris les élevages
contrairement à ce qui est dit ici ou là
la taille moyen des élevages en france
que ce soit dans le domaine bovin
allaitant bovins laitiers volaille y
compris truies et en moyenne
beaucoup plus petit que dans beaucoup de
pays européens et alors infiniment plus
petit par rapport à ce qui se passe à
l'étranger mais je crois que dans le
sens de votre question c'est plutôt de
la taille des élevages au sein même de
la ferme france et la ferme france sa
réalité c'est qu'elle est très diverse
mais alors vraiment très diverses en
termes de taille et cette diversité elle
tient d'ailleurs des territoires
eux-mêmes confère ce que l'exemple que
je venais tout à l'heure sur une
exploitation en zone intermédiaire
versus une exploitation y compris les
tiers en zone de montagne versus une
exploitation laitière dans ma belle
normandie que j'aime tant où vous aurez
détail d'exploitation qui sont très
différents
ce qu'on appelle le fameux taux de
chargement le nombre d'animaux versus la
taille de l'exploitation et donc on a
cette diversité là et donc la difficulté
c'est que il n'ya pas un modèle et ce
serait d'ailleurs même une erreur que de
se dire il n'ya qu'un modèle est donc il
nous faut trouver là aussi les justes
équilibres notamment dans la question
que vous posez je ne dis pas que que je
suis contre le paiement redistributif
jeudi qu' aujourd'hui le paiement
redistributif il à 10%
j'ai vérifié les allemands ils sont à 7
% aujourd'hui donc on est bien plus
redistributif que les allemands eux par
rapport à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure mais la question c'est qui est
ce qu'il faut aller encore plus loin ou
pas et c'est là où je dis attention
parce que si on va plus loin pour faire
les débats qu'on a eu depuis tout à
l'heure il se souvient il y en a pour
qui ça va c'est ça implique une
réduction de revenus significatifs il ya
un autre débat qu'on doit avoir qu'on
doit statuer c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
taille moyenne des exploitations aller
de 60 3 hectares alors que le paiement
redistributif ont fait sur 52 hectares
ce qui est favorable aux exploitations
de plus petite taille
ça c'est un des critères qu'on doit
statuer dans l'échelle globale de la
politique agricole commune mais qui ne
revient pas à toucher sur le taux de
paiement redistributif merci monsieur
ministre mam l'atrix compta merci
monsieur le ministre je sais que les
équilibres sont complexes et que les
exploitations agricoles sont de tailles
diverses
cependant vous nous avons vraiment
besoin d'une pacte social pour soutenir
les femmes et les hommes qui contribue à
une alimentation de qualité et pour
soutenir l'emploi et la création de
valeur ajoutée et
il faut que cette pac soutiennent notre
souveraineté alimentaire et une plus
grande attractivité des territoires
ruraux et lutter contre quand même un
accroissement endémique de la taille des
exploitations
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est monsieur fabien genêt pour le groupe
est républicain pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a
quelques jours monsieur le ministre vous
en atelier dans une tribune à revenir à
l'essentiel
naturellement les conceptions
gouvernementale en matière de ce qui est
essentiel et non essentielles peuvent
parfois nous interpeller mais en matière
agricole louis l'essentiel est
aujourd'hui en jeu et plus encore dans
le domaine de l'élevage bovin allaitant
alors que les agriculteurs ont un genou
à terre nous devons les aider à se
relever écriviez vous la question que je
souhaite vous posez ce soir c'est
finalement la question que se posent les
éleveurs de charolais de mon département
de la saône-et-loire
cette nouvelle version de la politique
agricole commune va-t-elle les aider à
se redresser
ou bien au contraire ne fera t-elle
qu'accentuer les difficultés actuelles
qui peu à peu dissuade les éleveurs de
poursuivre leur exploitation et les
jeunes de s'installer
trois ans après et galim les éleveurs de
bovins ont perdu 30% de leurs revenus
pour se contenter désormais en moyenne
de moins de 700 euros par mois et ses
maigres revenus correspondent justement
aux aides de la pac qui leur sont versés
diminuer ces aides cela veut donc dire
réduire encore leurs revenus
voilà l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est donc
de savoir monsieur le ministre si vous
vous engagez à leur garantir au minimum
le niveau des aides actuelles plus
précisément pouvez-vous préciser votre
projet de modification des aides
couplées aux bovins allaitants l'aide à
l'ue gb que vous souhaitez instauré sera
t-elle la même pour les bovins laitiers
et les bovins allaitants quel en sera le
montant
allez-vous les plafonné à 100 us gb
car les plafonner ces condamnés
plusieurs milliers d'exploitations de
bourgogne franche comté une chute de 30
à 50% de ces aides
en cas de baisse importante de ses aides
comment éviterez vous une
décapitalisation violentes dans les
élevages avec la conséquence que l'on
imagine sur les prix et la filière ce ne
sont pas là monsieur le ministre pour
reprendre vos mots des carabistouilles
mais des questions empreinte
d'inquiétude qui appelle des réponses
précises et chiffrées dont je vous
remercie
si cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur sur un département
comme la saône et loire mais qui là est
à une spécificité de votre département
département de la saône-et-loire il est
plutôt bénéficiaire en terme de
convergences donc plutôt bénéficiaire
aussi en termes de la convergence au
titre de l'écurie gym
et c'est d'ailleurs assez
caractéristiques des zones qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure et dont la saône
et loire est un est un exemple notamment
sur une partie département sur les zones
intermédiaires sur l'élevage dans la
position elle et de dire et je crois que
tout le monde le partage au delà des
inquiétudes d'une telle réforme
mais que tout le monde est assez
convaincu que passer à un système du gb
est une bonne idée
encore une fois le diable se cache dans
les détails il ya quoi comme paramètre
il ya effectivement faut-il faire un
juge et b commun eo2 laitiers et aux
allées temps on avait émis cette piste
début moi je pense que il faut faire
deux niveaux différents traitements
ainsi très précisément votre question
après sur les paramètres peut être
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on met des
ceux qui sont très différents et donc
vous avez des transferts qui sont trop
importants après et de la question c'est
comment vous les définissez in fine et
si vous en faites de différent comment
vous les définissez sur les questions
que vous évoquez il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de paramètres n'y a pas que celui du
nombre de
de plafond de sa me sens on a fait des
modèles on est passé à 120 de modèles on
est passé encore plus haut et aussi la
question du taux de chargement
on a fait des modèles à 1,4 des modèles
à 1,5 des modèles 1,6 des seuils est ce
qu'on applique exactement tous les mêmes
critères en fonction des filières à
l'étang pas des tendres laitiers on
s'est posé la question est faut-il ou
pas faire aussi un sujet sur le mixte
bref tous ces sujets là il nécessite
surtout beaucoup de concertation avec
tout le monde parce que c'est pas moi
qui vais les inventer ou mes équipes
uniquement on va le faire en sont donc
ces concertations elles sont toujours en
cours ce sur quoi je suis convaincu
d'ors-et-déjà au type de la concertation
c'est qu'il faut plutôt faire des
niveaux différents et un niveau unique
et sur l'ensemble des critères il faut
je crois faire en sorte que l'objectif
qu'on recherche sur la création de
valeur et l'attention que moi je porte
aux zones intermédiaires et aussi aux
territoires autres que les zones
intermédiaires fin d'année les
équilibres pardon monsieur le président
que ces équilibres à la fin soit bien
trouvé mais effectivement c'est un
existe un exercice d'orfèvrerie peu de
bien le faire et c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut faire vraiment dans la
concertation et prendre le temps
nécessaire
merci monsieur jeune et j'étais prêt à
monsieur le ministre à vous laisser mon
temps de parole de réponse pour vous
puissiez nous préciser des chiffres
parce que vous nous avez expliqué les
critères et les problématiques mais
reste le problème du chiffre est
effectivement de savoir si vous allez
pouvoir garantie garantir ce maintien du
niveau date pour que le revenu de ces
éleveurs ne baisse pas et je pense qu'à
l'heure où bientôt nous allons tous
aller nous coucher on peut méditer ce
que disait la fontaine dans ses fables
un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
et finalement en espèces et bien on ne
voudrait pas que ce soit un tiens vaut
mieux que moi tu leur merci chers
collègues
la parole est à mme cristina peluches et
pour l'europe et républicains pour 2
minutes 1 essai présidence du ministre
mes chers collègues
la déclinaison française du plan
stratégique national de la pac 2023 2027
inquiète les producteurs de grandes
cultures et en particulier la filière
betterave sucre alcool
qui requiert une attention particulière
à leurs fleurons de notre filière
agroalimentaire et de nos territoires
ruraux dans leur notamment elle connaît
depuis 2010 est en france une succession
de crises ça fait trois ans en effet que
le prix du sucre et sous le seuil d
alerte
le revenu des betteraviers reculé de
plus de 30 % des surfaces françaises ont
baissé de près de 20% pour revenir à
leurs niveaux sous quota 2016 et nous
avons perdu quatre sucreries en 2019
la crise de la jaunisse à elle fait
perdre un tiers de notre production
betteravière nationale en 2020
ces dernières semaines c'est le gel qui
impacte de manière inédite la filière en
détruisant quelques quarante mille
hectares de betteraves en cours de levée
et enfin on peut craindre une
réorientation des flux commerciaux suite
aux briques sites faisant ainsi peser
des risques supplémentaires sur les
débouchés la filière betteravière reçu
ministre est aujourd'hui un réel danger
vous insistez régulièrement sur la
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
de notre pays et cette filière y
participent
les enjeux sont tout autant agricole
qu'industriel il est donc il faut donc
répondre à l'urgence de ces situations
et est essentiel que le plan stratégique
national de la pac comporte un volet de
nature à sécuriser conforter erland
relancer la filière betterave au delà de
la question des dispositifs du 1er 2e
pilier accompagnant la structuration des
filières les professionnels appellent à
une stratégie sectorielle de gestion des
risques complémentaires du développement
de l'assurance récolte ils soutiennent
également la mise en oeuvre d'un
instrument de stabilisation des revenus
qui serait de nature à conforter le
revenu des betteraviers face aux chocs
économiques et aux sinistres sanitaires
non éligible au fm et ceux tels que la
jaunisse monsieur le ministre que
prévoit le gouvernement en termes de
priorités de dispositifs et de moyens
dans le cadre de la prochaine pac pour
sauvegarder et relancer la filière
betteravière vers ses ennemis
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci madame la sénatrice
je crois que je n'ai plus à démontrer
mon amour pour la filière betteravière
je resterai semences comme étant l'un
des ministres de la betterave et j'en
suis très fier mais une fois que une
fois que j'ai dit ça il ya plusieurs
sujets qui sont fondamentaux sur la
question betteravière si on rentre
vraiment dans les sujets précis il ya
d'abord une question de l'accessibilité
de l'éco régime
donc on est en train d'en discuter de
manière très précise
là aussi des concertations une
discussions sont en cours dans les
modèles initiaux il n'y avait pas entre
guillemets de spécificités sur les types
de plantes telles que la plante
betteraves et donc on est en train de
voir comment on peut faire évoluer le
dispositif la deuxième question plus
générale au delà des fonds de
stabilisation qui effectivement ont été
initiées dans certains textes européens
et qu'on essaie de mettre en oeuvre la
filière betterave et très allantes sur
le sujet ça envoie de manière plus
générale à la question de de la gestion
des risques
que ce soit par des fonds de
stabilisation que ce soit par d'autres
systèmes
ça renvoie fondamentalement la question
de la gestion des risques qui plus est
sur des gestions des risques il a sont
pas à proprement parler un risque
climatique un risque sanitaire même si
le risque sanitaire lui étant 13,5 un
train cinq ans liée aux risques
climatiques puisque les pucerons
viennent dès lors que les hivers n'ont
pas été assez froid et se démultiplient
ainsi et donc ça renvoie vraiment à tout
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur
comment on fait pour refondre le système
de la gestion des risques enfin
troisième élément très important c'est
comment la nouvelle politique agricole
commune peut également accompagner les
filières ça on a des instruments
notamment ce qu'on appelle les
programmes opérationnels et donc le
choix qu'on doit faire c'est mettons ou
pas de l'argent sur ses programmes
opérationnels si oui à quelle hauteur
mais là encore c'est des chemins si on
les met sur les programmes opérationnels
ça veut dire qu'on y met pas autre part
donc ça veut dire qu'on vient des
finances et par soit des aides couplées
soit par des des pb soit par les 2 enfin
c'est à nouveau un choix qu'on doit
faire
encore une fois il n'ya pas de plus il
n'y a que des plus avec des mois je
crois que c'est très important qu'on est
tous en tête et monsieur le ministre on
a un peu plus cher merci aux féministes
ravagé j'ai envie de vous dire peu
importe le volet 1
il ya juste urgence en fait à agir pour
soutenir cette filière betterave ans qui
se porte vraiment mal moi je le constate
sur le terrain
les agriculteurs ont perdu à peu près
400 à 500 euros l'hectare sur les
betteraves cette année et au niveau de
la somme un haut niveau de la seulement
il est il a été réduit de 30 à 50% voire
même des planteurs qui ont carrément
arrêter la betterave
voilà donc je pense que collègues mais
merci chers collègues
la parole est alors en saumon pour le
groupe est républicain pour deux minutes
monsieur le ministre les objectifs de la
pac 2021 et 2027 sont posés favoriser
une agriculture assurant souveraineté
santé alimentaire développer les actions
favorables aux objectifs
environnementaux et climatiques fixées
par l'union européenne ainsi que
renforcer le tissu économique des zones
rurales depuis 2014
la convergence progressive des aides a
eu pour conséquence une forte baisse des
aides directes pour certaines régions
dans les hauts de france au profit
d'autres régions la moyenne par
exploitation en sommes par exemple à
diminuer de 42% en dix ans en 2014 le
paiement redistributif passer de 5 à 10%
a permis à certaines régions de
compenser pour partie cette convergence
du paiement de base ce n'était pas le
cas quand somme qui de plus comme
d'autres départements ne bénéficient pas
des aides indemnité compensatoire de
handicap naturel du second pilier les
conséquent transfert du premier pilier
au second pilier ont donc eu un impact
négatif sur les paiements de base en ces
régions
la convergence aujourd'hui proposé
progressive à 80 % correspond en sommes
à une nouvelle diminution de 12 euros
par hectare soit 5,66 millions d'euros
et si la convergence était de 100 %
elle serait de 8 25 millions d'euros
vous devez dans le cadre du plan
stratégique national entre autres
définir les quatre modalités de la
convergence interne du montant de
paiement de base
la convergence nationale aux régionales
le seuil de déclenchement de la
convergence l'écart à la marine comblé
par convergence à l'imitation ou non
compensation ou non des pertes
engendrées par la convergence
monsieur le ministre quelles garanties
apportées vous sur le montant du premier
pilier et du transfert ou du non
transfert des monteurs du premier au
second pilier permis par le règlement
quelles convergences quel taux et quel
calendrier enfin pour limiter de
compenser les pertes successives pour
les systèmes de production des grandes
cultures dont dépendent les filières
industrielles comme le blé le protégé ne
ou la betterave permettrait vous un
accès aux échos régime simple à tous les
modèles de production avec la prison
des évolutions agro économiques comme la
gestion de l'eau ou l'agriculture de
précision et quelles convergences des
droits sera appliquée enfin dans le cas
de la convergence à quel niveau nous
fixer la part du paiement redistributif
dont on sait qu'il est certes facteur de
convergence des aides découplées mais
dont le doublement de la part de 10 à
20% du montant du premier pilier serait
le cas échéant en somme une perte
supplémentaire de 5 à 10 euros l'hectare
merci monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur vous voyez votre
intervention fait à lieux quelques
minutes après l'intervention de votre
collègue de saône-et-loire et c'est vrai
que si on saône et loire la convergence
est positif dans votre département de la
somme la convergence a un impact négatif
et donc la question qui est posée parce
qu'on l'avait tout à l'heure c'est de se
dire oui mais il faut faut-il aller très
rapidement sur la convergence et terre
qu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'on doit en
gros on a froid aller soit à hauteur de
85% soit à hauteur de 100%
faut-il aller très rapidement votre
collègue va dire oui parce qu'en plus ça
permet de d'améliorer encore plus le
revenu et votre intervention monsieur le
sénateur était vraiment tiré sur ce
revenu et vous vous allez dire ah bah
non surtout pas parce que pour le coup
ça va dégrader leurs revenus de vos
agriculteurs et parfois des agriculteurs
qui font la même activité puisque la
convergence est indépendante de
l'activité que vous faites aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on appelle vos bases
historiques bon premier point est donc
là moi il faut que je trouve un bon
équilibre pour dire de toute manière
faut continuer à faire cette convergence
je pense que personne ne remet en cause
la chose la question c'est faut-il la
faire très très très très vite va finir
à l'horizon 2027 au futile la faire
progressivement
vous aurez compris je crois dans mes
propos que je suis plutôt une personne
de la stabilité et je crois pas que la
stabilité est un manque de courage croit
parfois avoir de la stabilité fait aussi
du bien beaucoup
et que et que voilà le deuxième élément
sur les chorégies mouillart chez oui il
faut que c'est corrigé me soit
accessible en revanche attention parce
que c'est des débats qu'on a en ce
moment avec les filières l'écho régime
ça peut pas être une accessibilité
uniquement sur des moyens c'est
forcément sur des résultats des
autrement on doit continuer avec
l'ensemble des professionnels à être sûr
que ce soit sur des critères de résultat
et pas que des critères de moyens même
si je comprends la physionomie ou fun
pendant la philosophie de dire on fait
sur les moyens et pas sur des résultats
mais là pour reprendre l'expression de
votre collègue qui me citer faut jamais
raconter des carabistouilles si on n'est
que sur les moyens le psn
il passera pas les fourches caudines de
la commission européenne précisément
parce qu'on s'est tous battus pour que
ce soit obligatoire à tous ici on est
obligatoire à tous et qu'on puisse le
vérifier pour tous les états membres
ça peut pas être sûr des moyens parce
que là il y en a qui vont profiter de la
brèche les moyens au carré et qu'ils ne
feront jamais la convergence de ces
standards que l'on souhaite pour pouvoir
justement lutter contre la concurrence
des loyers pardon si mon raisonnement a
été un peu long mais tout ça pour dire
merci les régimes accessible et plutôt
des transitions que des bascules
importante merci la parole et à olivier
reitman pour le groupe l'est républicain
pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comme vous
le savez le sénat il reflète nos
territoires
c'est pourquoi j'aimerais fertiliser ce
débat par l'expression des agriculteurs
de territoire que je représente la haute
saône qui se disent aujourd'hui très
inquiet une inquiétude très légitime au
regard des nombreux points de désaccord
et de la très lente progression des
négociations en trilogue sur la réforme
de la pac
une inquiétude renforcée dès lors que
l'on mesure les conséquences que
pourraient avoir des arbitrages sur les
équilibres fragiles de certaines
exploitations en haute saône
monsieur le ministre plus de 80 % de la
surface agricole utile est en zone
défavorisée caractérisée par des sols
superficiels à très superficielle pour
pallier ces handicaps les efforts sont
incontestables en polyculture élevage
les agriculteurs développent des
systèmes particulièrement autonome
résilient et vertueux sur le plan
environnemental qui mérite une attention
toute particulière
la politique agricole commune à travers
le second pilier soutient et accompagne
ses exploitations situées en zone
défavorisée
or la pac va changer mais les
contraintes de production elle ne change
pas et s'aggrave même si la faible
qualité des sols et presque routinière
pour nos paysans
le fléau de l'excès de sécheresse est
une calamité à laquelle on ne se fait
pas dans ce contexte un changement
brutal de paradigme serait un coup
mortel porté à nos paysans dans les
revenus sont au plus bas et en cascade à
nos paysages et à notre biodiversité
pour éviter ce désastre une prise en
considération totale de li chn s'impose
en faveur des zones défavorisées simples
en haute-saône notamment mais aussi la
reconnaissance de certaines spécificités
comme celle des zones intermédiaires
l'état devrait également s'engager à
pallier la baisse des cofinancements
feader
monsieur le ministre j'en viens à ma
question dans quelle mesure ces
spécificités territoriales seront elles
prises en compte
en d'autres termes quelle agriculture
des territoires attendent demain ces
paysans des terres handicap et à faible
potentiel
merci merci cher collègue monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
président alors sur cette question la
prise en compte de difficultés
territoriales c'est d'ailleurs une
spécificité de la politique agricole
française et beaucoup de pays européens
qui ne prennent pas en compte la
spécificité des territoires et nous on a
fait ce choix là et je pense que c'est
un très bon choix
alors c'est vrai que pour maintenir
notamment ce niveau 10 chaînes je le
disais tout à l'heure en réponse à vos
collègues et de manière générale
maintenir le deuxième pilier ça
nécessite que l'état abondé à hauteur du
2e pilier à hauteur de 140 millions
d'euros par an sur cinq ans soit 700
millions d'euros
c'est un sacré de choix politique que
nous ferions dès lors que nous abonde de
riom à cette hauteur le deuxième pilier
pour pouvoir maintenir justement li chn
sur les zones intermédiaires hors zone
de ces zones intermédiaires éligibles à
li chn
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que certains de
vos collègues monde il faut abondé en
termes de paiement de base mais si on
abonde en termes de des paiements de
base ça se fait au titre du premier
pilier ça nécessite de faire un
transfert massif des aides couplées vers
les paiements de base massif et la
l'élevage ne s'en relève pas ce qu'il
faut vraiment avoir en tête c'est que et
y compris dans un département comme le
vôtre qui en est un très bon exemple le
fait d'avoir un écho au régime dès lors
que cet éco régime est accessible va
permettre d'avoir sur 20 à 30%
une convergence totale si je puis dire
qui va permettre de redonner plus à des
zones intermédiaires en tout cas votre
territoire on est un très bon exemple
les zones intermédiaires et on a aussi
des sujets des mae qui n'ont jamais
marché dans les zones intermédiaires il
nous faut cette fois ci trouver des
voies et moyens voilà sur le volet zone
intermédiaire sachant que le principal
sujet en jeu des zones intermédiaires
aujourd'hui encore plus demain c'est la
gestion du risque et surtout
l'accessibilité à l'eau vous connaissez
mon engagement dessus on va notamment
organisé d'écran varennes de l'eau
agricole et du changement climatique
dans les prochains jours vu que c'est ma
dernière prise de parole je voulais
juste faire le constat que vous voyez
est vraiment remercier la qualité des
débats mais qu'on voit bien que vous
avez tous dit on a besoin mon territoire
a besoin il soit absolument on comprend
que c'est difficile mais il ya urgence
et il nous faut aider et c'est sa toute
la difficulté dans laquelle moi je me
retrouve c'est que encore une fois
déclin plus quelque part il ya un mois
autre part et que je dois trouver des
équilibres qu'à la fin des fins je pense
que je me prendrai les remontrances de
tout le monde
peut-être que l'équilibré des
remontrances de tout de tous montrons
que j'ai essayé de trouver ce bon point
d'équilibré
c'est la difficulté de l'exercice c'est
vraiment la difficulté d'exercice
heureusement on le fait dans un budget
qu'on a su préserver encore une fois
grâce à l'appui de la france mais en
tout cas si à la fin les résultats des
uns et des autres sont soit considérée
comme pas suffisant soit que ceux
considérés comme n'étant trop ou pas
suffisant et y est juste une certitude
c'est que j'aurais fait ses choix avec
le plus de concertation possible et le
plus de professionnalisme possible c'est
un engagement de moyens pas forcément de
résultats perdons nous contredire par
rapport à la réponse de tout à l'heure
monsieur le sénateur mais je crois que
c'est comme ça aussi qu'on fait avancer
les choses
en tout cas dans le cadre d'intérêt
scène avec et je voudrais remercier des
services qui derrière moi travaillent
jour et nuit depuis de nombreux mois sur
cette question pour mener ces
concertations et qui vous l'avez vu
relève d'une certaine forme de
complexité en tout cas un grand merci
d'avoir permet d'en débattre et je pose
à votre sagacité juste une question il
s'avère que la loi stipule qu il y a
beaucoup de concertation à faire
beaucoup beaucoup de concertation mais
ne stipule pas qu'il y ait des débats au
niveau des chambres
vous l'avez fait de vous même je pense
que c'est très important mais c'est
peut-être une réflexion collégiale aa
voir dans le cadre de ses politiques
agricoles comme si monsieur le ministre
pour conclure le débat la parole est à
monsieur franck montaugé pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste républicains pour
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
au terme de ce débat de contrôles
demandés par le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
je voudrais remercier tous les
intervenants des groupes du sénat et
vous remercier monsieur le ministre pour
les positions il approche de
gouvernement que vous avez exprimées
alors dans ce moment inédit de mise au
point du plan stratégique national dont
l'issue aura de lourdes conséquences
pour nos agriculteurs et nos territoires
et un suivant la phrase du philosophe
que puis je connaître comme est il
permis d'espérer et que dois je faire
je vais m'attacher à conclure ce débat
d'abord nous connaissons le budget dont
bénéficiera la ferme france le contexte
du cadre financier pluriannuel était
difficile on l'a dit avec le départ des
anglais contributeurs nets
il est facilement équivalent à celui de
la paire de précédentes 1000 sera en
baisse à euros constants
l'euro constant qui est la seule unité
de mesure sérieusement utilisable pour
comparer des budgets sur le mieux
période donc pertes en matière de
soutien qu'il faudra compenser par
ailleurs vous l'avez dit pour mieux
maintenir la compétitivité et le revenu
qui en est pour moi une composante
essentielle
le plan stratégique national et est
aussi construit sur la base de
l'enveloppé nationale et il doit
répondre à des objectifs on le sait
maintenant un principe cardinal
préalable auquel nous tenons les
agriculteurs français doivent pouvoir
tous vivre décemment de leur métier
la nation doit leur assurer un revenu
équitable tout en répondant aux attentes
de la société en matière de ses qualités
de santé et d'impact sur l'environnement
et le climat
avec un budget en baisse en asie et des
marchés que nous ne maîtrisons pas et
c'est un sujet en soi qui n'a pas
d'ailleurs été abordés où va-t-on
trouver les moyens de répondre à cet
objectif
d'abord il faut rééquilibrer les
pouvoirs dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement alimentaire égaler
une première version a été malgré nos
avertissements de l'époque un échec
il est urgent de réouvrir le débat sur
la base d'une construction du prix payé
par le premier acheteur intégrant des
critères de coûts de production dans un
cadre contractuel pluriannuel tools
inverse du ruissellement dont le premier
américain viennent de nous dire que ça
n'a jamais marché
les paysans français l'avait compris
depuis longtemps à leurs dépens il
aurait fallu certainement les écouter et
que dire aux agriculteurs qui ont été
injustement et dramatiquement sortie de
la carte des zones défavorisées
pour beaucoup d'entre eux le revenu
correspondait au lycée la chaîne pour un
travail h 24 7 jours sur 7 je le
rappelle au passage
alors vous comprenez monsieur le
ministre pour cela comme pour ceux qui à
qui on a dit que les primes à la vache
allaitante vont baisser que le désespoir
et la colère ne sommes pas loin ne
faites pas l'erreur de jouer protéines
contre élevage allaitant la réforme de
l'ue gb doit apporter aux élèves et aux
éleveurs pas les affaiblir enveloppe
constante nous pensons qu'il faut cibler
les aides sur les systèmes productifs à
un jeu comme le bio l'agriculture de
conservation des sols les démarches
qualité certifiée ab achevé le voir
errer sur les appellations et autres
marques de pays garantir la qualité des
denrées alimentaires et la santé en
réponse aux attentes de la société passe
indéniablement par ces démarches qu'il
faut soutenir davantage dans une
perspective de soutien au renouvellement
des générations
nous vous demandons de plafonner à 60000
euros les aides du t1 est de mieux
cibler les aides du p2 les échos chaîne
du pn doivent intégrer les dispositifs
de valorisation des externalités
positives de l'agriculture à travers la
mise en place de paiements pour services
environnementaux pse plus largement la
notion d'aménité rural doit se traduire
par une meilleure reconnaissance de la
place de la ruralité dans notre pays
c'est un enjeu national qui déborde le
strict le cadre strict de l'agriculture
le chantier doit être ouvert monsieur le
ministre c'est ce que nous vous
demandons l'objectif de préservation des
paysages et de la biodiversité doit être
travaillé à l'aune de ce concept
d'aménité rural que votre conseil le
conseil général agriculture vous propose
de mettre en oeuvre il en va aussi de la
dynamisation et du soutien au
développement des zones rurales les
collectivités locales
ils y auront toute leur place en lien
avec l'agenda rural la question cruciale
du renouvellement des générations
passera aussi par la définition de
l'actif agricole et nouvelles
dispositions de gestion du foncier
agricole y contribueront aussi
grandement
nous souhaitons aussi que votre feuille
de route sur les zones intermédiaires
puis se prendre en compte la diversité
des territoires en difficulté les zones
intermédiaires ne se limite pas à la
diagonale charente-maritime moselle
ou au territoire de grandes cultures
bien des systèmes productifs en grande
difficulté peuvent y prétendre comme
ceux de polyculture élevage qui
caractérise par exemple vous le savez
mon département du gers
nous souhaitons pouvoir travailler avec
vous là dessus monsieur le ministre le
revenu et la compétitivité passeront
aussi par la protection et la création
de ressources naturelles au premier rang
desquels nous plaçons la ressource en
eau vous avez ouvert le dossier et nous
sommes disponibles pour travailler avec
vous sur ce sujet majeur est urgent qui
ne concerne pas que le sud de la france
il faudra donc aussi accroître la
compétitivité sans sacrifier les enjeux
de qualité alimentaire de santé et d'un
pack des productions sur l'environnement
si les sifi coucours et autres plans
alimentaires territoriaux se développe
et c'est indispensable
ils ne suffiront pas seul à régler la
question du revenu et de la
compétitivité agricole nationale quatre
ans après que le sénat aient voté à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi
socialiste qu'elle j'avais travaillé
avec henri cabanel visant à développer
les outils de gestion des risques en
agriculture vous ré ouvrir le chantier
c'est une bonne chose et nous sommes
prêts là aussi à travailler avec vous
pour conclure un mot sur les enjeux
internationaux la pac pour notre pays
vous demandons monsieur le ministre de
faire en sorte que les producteurs
français soient traités équitablement
donc que les critères d'exportation soit
équivalent aux critères d'importation et
intègre notamment la problématique du
carbone ainsi que des normes sanitaires
équivalente
et je vous rappelle le souhait du sénat
de pouvoir discuter du ceta dans cet
hémicycle l'agriculture française ne
doit pas ne peut pas être la variable
d'ajustement d'autres secteurs
économiques nationaux sucette il a un
jeu la souveraineté alimentaire
nationale passe aussi par là je vous
remercie tous pour votre participation
merci mes chers collègues effectivement
d'avoir participé à ces débats merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir répondu
avec précision à l'ensemble des
questions
[Musique]